I'm Friday town except maybe supposedly
crucial error of holy the fall
presidents tab1 siyang when since 1979
the United States saw the policy of
studying neutrality with regard to the
question Taiwanese independence weeks
old agreed in principle with the one
China rhetoric at economy Chinese
espouse but we veer asleep prevents a
China from breast of action against
Taiwan trans phone call with Taiwan was
supposedly there for a breach of both
decorum and policy expertise which is
truly frightening supposedly well all
that's idiotic okay Barack Obama spends
his presidency over who on
well-calibrated foreign policy on behalf
of concessions to even change from
pending around hundreds of billions of
dollars to continue promoting terrorism
to handing Russian dictator Vlad Putin
control of Crimea in Syria from
reinforcing the crumbling Castro regime
in Cuba it's weakening America's
military and thus opening the door way
to Chinese aggression in the South China
Sea Obama's foreign policy has been
basically in your endless procedures of
placing our enemies in a beneficial
position Trump making a phone call to
Taiwan that's kind of the opposite as I
wrote last week Trump either knows what
he's doing with Taiwan or he really
doesn't if he does if his goal is to
demonstrate to the Chinese that de
tantas ending thanks to their aggression
that's not the worst thing in the world
that's actually a pretty good thing
China has been building a regional
sphere of influence that is only set to
expand as Trump pulls out of the
trans-pacific partner or for Chinese
interests in Southeast Asia shortly can
clear the security threats to American
allies in the region will not be
tolerated that would be a real positive
well if Trump's goal is to use I want as
leverage against China and economic
warfare Robert that is a foolish thing
taiwan deserves our support against
china not to be sold out in order to
thwart supposed to chinese trade
manipulation what about it from has no
goal if as you seem to stand on twitter
is just winging it well and we'll find
out either he'll back down or he won't
and that will be the policy but the
sheer panic over the taiwan phone call
is overblown you don't know yet what the
call priest ages it's just amateur hour
sure we should be worried but even if it
is amateur hour obama to suppose a
professional blue worsted from worse
than Trump did purposefully with the
various intent over and over again I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
alrighty so much to get to today here on
ben shapiro show there will be some some
good from bad Trump will get to that and
just decide now basically do the theme
of today's show as well as the next four
years and a lot to get to about sort of
the perversion of conservatism and the
soul-sucking of the Republican Party
will talk about a lot of that plus the
Democrats continue to be completely in
disarray but first we have to say hello
and where r and calm so every 13 seconds
in the United States there's a home
burglary and one of the ways that home
burglars get access to your house is
that ring the doorbell and then if they
figure nobody totally break in they
don't want to confront you they don't
want to be dealing with you with a
shotgun on the other side of the door
ring calm helps prevent this procedure
if they ring the doorbell then you can
pick up the doorbell anywhere you are
rings direct to your phone there's a
camera so you can see who it is that's
at your door and they will think that
you're at home so they won't break in
plus it allows you to know who's
knocking at the front door which is
obviously a useful thing when I'm away
and my kids are at home my wife's at
home I like to be able to know who's at
home and whether my kids and wife are
safe or not rinko makes that happen they
also have what they call the ring of
security kit and the ring of security
kit includes a video ring video doorbell
for the front door and ring stick up cam
with wireless weatherproof HD camera
that keeps an eye on other parts of your
property again ring calm is one of these
advertisers I have it's so good that
actually spent my own money on their
products and went out and bought extra
product from them because I I believe in
their product so much ring calm is the
place to go and you / Ben ring calm /
Ben you get one hundred and fifty
dollars off of that ring of security
kids that's pretty significant discount
ring calm / been millions of homeowners
including me use ring use ring calm /
been for that promotional discount okay
tell us to get to today your best
Shapiro show we begin you know I will
just play the good from bad Trump theme
upfront because that's basically the
theme of program so we may as well just
have fun with it which one will be
yay good Trump a drum whoo okay so we
start with good Trump so good Trump is
really sort of mediocre Trump and that
is Donald Trump in the whole Taiwanese
debacle so the media are really over
playing their hand here the media are
making a huge deal out of the fact that
Donald from picked up the phone when the
president of Taiwan called as I say
they're really only three ways that to
break this down way number one he's
adult and he just picked up the phone
not knowing who's on the other end
unlikely possible possibility number two
he has a cohesive thought-out policy
he's trying to take off the Chinese he's
trying to tell them that he will not be
stopped by there by their aggression
that would be really good way number
three is that he's actually saying all
these tough things about Taiwan because
he wants to broker a better trade deal
with China still not my favorite thing
because that would basically be using
Taiwan as a chit in some sort of trading
game not my favorite thing but we don't
know the answer to any of this yet so we
can sort of hold off judgment is it good
is it bad we don't know so this is sort
of mediocre Trump Mike Pence hits it
right on the head the vice president's
alexia to right on the head when he says
listen all you people in the media
you're going nuts over this stuff but
the fact is that and what he did with
you but you were fine with it it's a
little mystifying to me that that
President Obama can can reach out to a
murdering dictator in in Cuba in the
last year and be hailed as a hero for
doing it and president-elect a Donald
Trump takes a courtesy call from the
democratically elected leader in Taiwan
and it's become it's become something of
a controversy or anything okay and
that's exactly right the fact is that
the media were head over heels when
Barack Obama trotted out a literal
fiction to them about the Iran deal they
were they were just in love with with
Obama even though the bottle on attack
was happening in France at the same time
that Obama was visiting Cuba he went to
a baseball game that were cool with that
the media have been fine with every
stupid thing that Obama has done his
entire presidency and so it seems a
little bit hypocritical for them to get
some upset now now one of the things I'm
going to say on the program today and
this is a consistent principle I feel
like we sort of have to in the in the
aftermath of trumps victory we sort of
have to go back to first moral
principles in order to determine how
we're going to cover this right because
the fact is the way I see it we don't
root for politicians here on the band
Shapiro show we don't because this isn't
a sports game okay I'm not interested in
the personal victory or loss
Donald Trump I'm much more interested in
the principles I espouse and whether he
represents them now that he's president
select I would like him to all of the
good conservative things he promised and
some good conservative like see him not
to silly things so what I've said I said
this on Twitter over the weekend this is
not baseball right don't root for the
team for the principal cast number one
number two a game that we should not get
in the habit of playing is the game well
I'll start worrying about from doing X
when the Democrats stop doing acts right
so I'll stop worrying about Trump being
an amateur when the Democrats stop being
a mature risk ok this is this is pure
I'll logic it's childish logic I should
be worried about the president-elect of
the United States doing things I don't
like whether or not the Democrats are
doing things I don't like I assume the
Democrats and the media will do things I
don't like so when we get too bad Trump
in just a second I'm gonna explain but
this sort of this sort of silly logic
which doesn't make any sense this notion
that when Trump does something bad it's
okay because Democrats have also done
that bad thing it just doesn't work I
don't like that argument in any sense
but my Pence's right that the media's
treatment of the pence is right in the
sense that immediate his treatments of
Obama their willingness to overlook all
of his foreign policy sins and then call
it crazy just crazy when Trump picks up
the phone with Taiwan that's that's
totally out of it they're out of their
minds John Bolton who's up for Secretary
of State he visited I guess from our on
Fridays he sort of back in the mix they
announced by the way they're a bunch of
new people who are up for it also they
said Jon Huntsman former ambassador to
China under President Obama that he
might be out before if he came out today
and came out in favor of what Trump had
done with Taiwan arrest ellerson who's
the CEO of Exxon very warm toward
Vladimir Putin and he's up for Secretary
of State Dana Rohrabacher who is a
congressman from California nice guy
very very pro-putin he's up for
Secretary of State apparently and so the
field expands now I really think they
were gonna end up with somebody who's in
the original field I think this is sort
of a trump Ian reality TV show moment
where he just expands the fields and
week 5 of the reality TV show than
windows it back down to the person that
you thought was going to win all along
my guess is that in the end this is
going to come down again to john bolton
regionally on a mitt romney is some the
original pics but i could be surprised
obviously this is why they was why
reality TV shows get good ratings
because we don't know what's happening
next anyways Bolton said
that Beijing should not decide who we
get to talk to what Trump did is just
fine the President of the United States
should talk to whomever he wants if he
thinks it's in the interest of the
United States and nobody in Beijing gets
dictate who we talked to and in Trump
echo down on Twitter and I think that's
right listen if he picks Bolton for
Secretary of State on a happy camper
Bolton that state mad as a defense that
would be terrific but but then we start
getting too then we start getting to
bathroom then we start getting to
bathroom and bad Trump is the stuff that
he's been doing about the economy so I
mentioned last Thursday we talked about
the deal that he did with carrier where
he basically wheedled threatened cajoled
them into keeping a thousand shops in
Indiana and then everybody wanted ta
Donald you did a great job keeping a
thousand to and I said hold up a second
we have to figure out how he kept a
thousand jobs there and if you kept a
thousand jobs there in a bad way that is
something that we should call out
because again I'm not in the business of
its ok when Democrats do it it's bad
when Democrats do but it's okay when we
do that's not something I'm interested
in Barack Obama regularly threatened
company's insurance companies banks the
auto manufacturers you threaten them on
a regular basis all the time and by
threatening them can you get them to do
what he wanted and I would say that's
economic fascism because that's what it
is if you look back to Mussolini if you
look back to Hitler if you look back to
any of the Franco if you look at any of
the fascist States of Europe the way
that they did business was corporatism
corporatism was the idea that the
government could leverage private
businesses into doing what they wanted
and they can also bribe private
that's not something I'm for the
government has no place picking winners
and losers the government has no place
threatening businesses for engaging in
open market activity open market
activity free market activity makes
better products before jeepers for
consumers the idea of the carrier just
did something wonderful happened to
carrier because a thousand jobs stayed
in the United States not because of
lower tax rates not because of broader
better economic climate but just because
Trump basically threatened them that's a
very nasty thing and Trump basically
double down on that over the weekend so
over the weekend here are some of his
tweets he tweeted rexnord of Indiana is
moving to Mexico and rather viciously
firing all of its 300 workers this is
happening all over our country no
and this is economic fascism they're not
viciously firing their 300 workers
Donald Trump has fired workers before
two in fact as I recall his slogan on TV
was you're fired if I efi it if you
don't remember that just look at an old
tape from five years ago three years ago
right it was you're fired was he dishes
dishes but according to trump it's
vicious because he doesn't want them to
do it this is the language of economic
totalitarianism the idea that you you're
viciously firing your workers congrats
see the governor is participating in a
shift of jobs away from expensive
unionized areas out of the country that
by the way will keep some people
employed at rexnord in the United States
the alternative presumably is for them
to continue to shell out large dollars
for these unions to shell out large
dollars for these jobs never to
outsource to go out a business and
everybody's unemployed anyway and the
American company no longer produces
products for people that are good and we
no longer get any tax revenue so those
are the alternatives okay the way the
free market economics works you're going
to move your your jobs we are the jobs
to the cheapest and the best that's a
good thing it means the people get to
consume products at a better price it
also means that those companies stay
competitive in the global marketplace
which allows them to grow and thrive no
company grows and thrives simply based
on protectionism the minute that the
tariffs are taken away they collapse
that's exactly what happens to the
automaker's in the 1950s 60s and 70s in
the United States we see the world's
dominant automakers in the 70s and the
60s they're hotter severe protectionism
was put in place for the auto industry's
unionization took place really really
bad union contracts were signed and then
when those protections were removed then
the auto industry basically collapsed
with all the Toyotas flowing into the
country that's what happened to the auto
industry or perturbs all that does is
build up these bloated overweight
industries that are shipped as soon as
they have to enter into a global
marketplace but here is Trump targeting
retinoid saying they're viciously fired
like they're sitting around like the
boss they're sitting around there but
you know what it'd be cheaper to keep
the jobs here in Indiana but screw that
screw those workers you hate those guys
fire them all let's go to Mexico nobody
does that but this sort of language is
charged language was populist nonsense
it really is kind of gross and then
Trump continued here's some more of his
280 tweeted and this was his policy
tweets this is nonsense it says the u.s.
is going to substantially reduce taxes
and regulations on businesses
any business that leaves our country for
another country fires its employees
builds a new factory or plant in the
other country and then thinks it will
sell its product back into the US
without retribution or consequence is
wrong and language punishment again the
federal government is going to punish
you for engaging in free market activity
and I wonder if he's going to punish all
the auto companies for moving jobs out
of Detroit even if they went bankrupt
says there will be a tax on our students
to be strong border of thirty-five
percent for these companies wanted to
sell their product cars AC units etc
back across the border this tax will
make leaving financially difficult but
these companies are able to move between
all 50 states with no tax or tariffs
being charged please be forewarned prior
to making a very bit it's making a very
expensive mistake and then all caps the
United States is open for business I
said this is like building an economic
Berlin Wall and it is the idea is to
keep the business inside the United
States even at the cost of bankrupting
the business right because the only way
that you're going to be able to make the
businesses in the United States
competitive you tell them they can't
outsource their labor is by increasing
tariffs on foreign products right
increasing the tax on foreign products
which means you and I all the consumers
we have to spend lots and lots of money
to keep these jobs in the United States
okay which is stupid because the job
stay in the united states and different
sectors that doesn't mean everybody's a
winner in the global economy of course
that's not true it doesn't mean every
sectors winner in the global economy of
course that's not true at the beginning
of the Republic ninety percent of the
people living in the United States we're
farming today it's three percent what
happens all the farmers while they paid
in the global economy they did what
happened to all the people who
manufactured did the the wagons that
preceded the cars will they all went out
of business does that mean that we ought
to just put tariffs on cars and destroy
the car industry to make sure that the
wheelwrights Union still gets their pay
of course no that's silly and if we
really want to make sure that quote
unquote jobs stay in the United States
regardless of the quality of jobs or the
quality of the product we really should
do is gay and technology Amazon go home
just get these really amazing grocery
stores or apparently you can walk in
your products off the shelf stick them
in a bag and walk out you don't have to
pay make it the computers are able to to
gauge what products we took and then
just charge it to you directly so you
never have to worry about a checkout
line you don't have to worry about
waiting in line or even self scanning
you don't have to do any of that stuff
anymore which is super cool presumably
Trump would want to ban that kind of
stuff or if not he'd have to explain why
this is different he'd want to ban that
sort of stuff to make sure that the
groceries still haven't are able to hire
a lots of people this is the problem
okay the purpose of an economy is not to
create jobs the purpose of an economy is
to create the best products at the
lowest possible price and that in turn
creates jobs because in order to create
those products in order to have people
who buy those products you need to have
people who have jobs right but the idea
that you just want the only indicator of
the health of an economy is the
unemployment rate is absolute stupidity
it's always been stupidity the Soviet
Union had one hundred percent
unemployment employment rate a zero
percent unemployment rate and everybody
was impoverished cuba's and one hundred
percent employment rate because it's a
communist country so you can just force
everybody into labor or call them
employees for sitting on a park bench
and playing dominoes bullying different
economy is not to create jobs the point
of an economy is to create products and
services that you and I want to trade
with each other to make both our lives
better an economy that only seeks to
create jobs is not worried about making
everybody's life better it's worried
about making some people's life better
an economy that worries about creating
better products and services that's an
economy that is a balance ristic economy
where you and I can engage in trade and
barter and come up with the best
possible solutions for ourselves that's
a free market economy Trump apparently
is not super in favor of that this thing
says the very end where he says the
United States is open for business let
me tell you something if I haven't
opened for business sign on my door
usually there's not an asterisk and then
below that it's written and if you don't
come in here and do business then will
threaten you if you come in here to side
the product is too expensive than you
need will threaten you heyhey Trump
wants his big beautiful berlin wall of
the economy and what's amazing about
this is that so many people are falling
into this so Mike Pence I'm really
disappointed in so far man he was
supposed to be the guy who we voted for
essentially right he was the one who was
going to make sure the conservatism won
the day in the end that was the idea
Pence is now fully embracing the Trump
Ian economics economics again if nothing
to do with reality apparently said to
the new york times last week quote the
free market has been sorting it out and
america has been losing and then
said every time every time nonsense
absolutely nonsense America's most
powerful country in human history not
because it's protectionists okay
protectionists countries do not drive
they don't I got into an argument with a
guy from MarketWatch about this over the
weekend I said name the countries that
have become wealthy based on tariffs and
building infrastructure he said China
and I said it's absolutely false they
had tariffs and they were building
infrastructure back during nows day the
difference is they actually took some
market liberalizing steps they
privatized a bunch of property they
privatized a bunch of businesses and
they still have significant debt
problems and they've had to stock market
crashes in the last year the idea that
the China is an economic rival to the
United States not on a per capita basis
they sure as hell aren't and they
enslaved a billion people in order to do
it in the Wall Street Journal apparently
Penn said quote a trump White House
would eschew many of the free market
principles that have guided prior
Republican administrations including
injecting itself into the personnel and
long-term operating decisions of
individual companies that's the economic
effect it's no different from what Obama
has done it's no different from what
Hillary we've done it's no different
from what cassius of the cast have done
seriously injecting the government its
personnel and long-term operating
decisions of individual companies of the
individual companies and then on Sunday
here's what Mike Pence had to say about
Donald Trump's economics think what
you're going to see and the
president-elect will make those
decisions on a on a day-by-day basis in
the course of the transition of course
the administration man you said make
these decisions on it on a day-by-day
basis isn't that picking winners and
losers I mean Sarah Palin calls a crony
capitalism no I don't think it's picking
winners and losers at all what what the
what the president-elect did with
carrier we simply reach out one American
to another and just ask them to
reconsider he told them we're going to
do exactly what we said we would do in
this campaign we're going to make the
American economy more competitive we're
going to get tougher and smarter on
trade deals and that was changed
circumstances from when I picking
winners and losers he just reached out
one American to another really divided
called up Karen so guys can you not
shift those jobs down south what I'd
like for you to do is instead to be 65
million dollar bonds an idiot look 7
million dollars
tax benefits from the skin vidya but
basically least 58 million us as one
Americans one other I'm just asking you
know it turns out that that's not what
happened what happened here is that
Donald Trump called up Carrie are you
running that's what happened and what's
amazing is how many people are okay with
this it's all fine cuz trunks big
victory guy comes the big victory guy
principles out the window we have to
root for trunk personally not for
principals who ought to see spouse we
have to move for him personally on a
personal level we have to sit here and
we have to pray for him to succeed not
for his policies to succeed but for him
personally to succeed so glenn reynolds
who i usually love when Donald's
libertarian instapundit here's what he
wrote celebrating the carrier deal quote
Trump went ahead and delivered a
conspicuously kept campaign promise that
benefits the little guy sends a signal
of caring the top of macroeconomics does
not FDR nudists his medial economic
policies were mostly snake oil according
to a study by UCLA economists they
actually prolong the Great Depression by
seven years but FDR made people feel
like you cared even though he was a rich
man from New York would never been
poured himself now another rich man from
New York seems to be repeating the
formula FDR gave the Democrats two
decades of political dominance today's
Democrats should be worrying trunk could
do the same for the Republican Party but
I have a question Republicans be
worrying that FDR is back in the white
house except he's calling himself a
Republican I mean come on he's I mean
here he is here is a libertarian glenn
reynolds openly saying Trump is engaging
in FDR new dot a new deal style
snake-oil random he calls the snake oil
but that's okay he's elisa pisses off
the democrats ok i don't care about
pissing off democrats I care about doing
the right thing if that pisses off
Democrats that's their problem but this
is really dangerous stuff here's the
editorial board for investors business
daily quota it is about the carrier deal
it means an end to eight years in which
President Obama instead of supporting us
companies arrogantly sold the business
leaders and treated business as an
either piggy banks to be rated or as
enemies to be brought to heel through
regulations and mandates wait wait the
carrier deal did that that's what
chunkies did that he just folded a
business leader and then treated a
business as a piggy bank to be rated or
as an enemy to be brought to heel but he
just tweeted one second ago rexnord of
Indiana is moving Mexico and viciously
firing its 300 workers that sound like a
guy is trafficking in the free mark
does that sound like that to you now
again I hope and I pray that Donald
Trump reverses himself on this but in
order for him to achieve that if you
want him Deb sacks full presidency you
need no snake oil you need an economic
policy and favors free trade you need an
economic policy that doesn't favor the
sort of garbage he's been selling people
I understand that he was lying to people
during the campaign you should too he
was when he's going into blue-collar
areas and saying I'm gonna bring back
all your jobs no cost we're just gonna
tear if it up the wazoo and everything
will be hunky-dory that's not how
economics works it may be that snake oil
salesmen it's not snake oil and I'm in
the business of trying to tell the truth
and I believe that the American people
when they hear the truth will understand
the truth because if we don't believe
the truth means anything if we don't
believe that the truth can win out then
what the hell are we doing in this
business why not should be Democrats why
don't just lie to everybody all the time
why not sell them a bill of goods that's
never going to come due and then I guess
we'll win a lot and yay we'll have 20
years of dominance but this is this is
just such a special silliness by the way
speaking of silliness apparently Ivanka
Trump please remember Donald Trump's
head who's going to put his businesses
in a blind trust would be run by his
children all three of these kids are now
moving to DC so it's going to make that
blind trust kind of awkward and ivanka
trump met with Al Gore today at Trump
Tower and so apparently did Donald Trump
apparently that a long expensive meeting
about climate change don't like
beautifully now we're going to continue
over at Taylor wired.com this brings us
to the end of Facebook and YouTube but
you should listen of course on
soundcloud night UNS and and you'll get
to to the democrats imploding also but
go today lee weyer calm subscribe to
subscribe become an annual subscriber
today then you still get a free copy of
my novel signed but true allegiance and
doing really well and you're going to
want to check it out plus you get access
to the mailbag you get to email me and
we'll email with each other same thing
with with amp and clave ins show you get
rid of the ads on the site all those
annoying pop-up ads go i plus we have
plenty of goodies coming I think in the
next few weeks we're going to have a
shapiro merchandise store which should
be really exciting you get big discounts
if you're with your manual member so go
over today lee weyer calm right now
becoming the annual member and and thank
you for for being part of the team that
brings us the largest conservative
podcast in America
[Music]